in this course you will learn how to
create a full stack application using
mongodb for the database Java and spring
boot for the back end and react for the
front end Farhan has seen choudhary
teaches the back end section of this
course and Gavin lawn teaches the front
end section of the course both these
instructors are very experienced and
have created many popular courses the
project featured in this course is a
great example of the creation of a
separation of concerns between the
client code and the server code by
implementing a Loosely coupled
architecture these two parts implemented
using different Technologies can evolve
in parallel and independently from one
another so let's start learning from
Farhan
hello everyone welcome to the Java with
mongodb course on the free code Camp
YouTube channel
I am Farhan Hassan chotri one of the
instructors in this course and I will
teach you all about developing a backend
API using Java springboard and mongodb
the other half of the course will be
taught by Gavin long hi I'm Kevin lawn
I'm a full stack developer and have over
20 years experience working as a
software developer in this course I'm
going to be playing the role of a
front-end developer and my
responsibility will be to demonstrate
building a front end using react.js
the spa application that we are going to
create will use HTTP get requests to
appropriately retrieve data from a
remote server through communicating with
the relevant api's endpoints and HTTP
post requests will also be made to the
relevant endpoints to appropriately save
data on the server side
of course our data will be stored within
a mongodb database on the relevant
remote server
so without further Ado let's jump in and
start working on our API in the
beginning of the course you will have to
download two new softwares from the
internet the first one being Java
development kit or jdk if you already
have jdk installed on your system you
should be good to go with that but just
in case you do not have it installed I'd
suggest you navigate to oracle.com Java
Technologies slash downloads the link
will be in description once you have
landed on the download page for Java you
may find multiple versions of jdk
available as of the recording of this
course there the latest version is Java
19 and the latest LTS version is Java
17. htfc stands for long-term support
and jdk 17 will receive updates
until September 2024
jdk 19 on the other hand will receive
updates only until March 2023 and will
be superseded by jdk 20. in many cases
when you are deploying a Java
application on a production server it
suggested that you use lto's release for
better stability and for this course I
will stick to Java 17 since that's the
latest LTS now depending on when you are
watching this course there may be a new
LDS release so feel free to download and
install that so I'll switch to Java 17
and since I am on Windows I will go to
Windows and the 64-bit installer as you
can see it's only
152.85 megabytes and depending on your
internet connection you it may take a
few minutes to download
once you have downloaded the installer
make sure you have installed it on your
system like any other software you have
done before and since the installation
is so straightforward I will not spend a
lot of time showing you the entire
process
after you have finished installing jdk
on your computer open up your terminal
window and write Java c space Double
Dash
a
and if you do not get any errors from
this command
this is a positive sign and as it says
Java C 17.0.5 which indicates that I
have successfully installed
7.17.0.5 version of the jdk now Java C
is the short for Java compiler which you
may or may not have already guessed
apart from this command you can also use
Java Double Dash version to check the
version of your Java runtime environment
and as you can see it says 17.0.5 LTS
which means we are good to go
since you have successfully installed
the jdk on your computer next up you
will need a good code editor or IDE
when it comes to Java there are plenty
of options out there you can go with
eclipse or maybe configure Visual Studio
code but I would suggest that you go
with IntelliJ IDEA
now the people at jet brains are known
for making really good Ides and when it
comes to Java IntelliJ IDEA is pretty
much the industry standard
although the ultimate version can cost
you some money there is also a free
version available by the name of
Community Edition
now to download IntelliJ IDEA navigate
to jetbrains.com idea download again the
link will be in description and look for
the Community Edition this is the black
download button here and depending on
your platform IE Windows Mac OS or Linux
you may get a different format for
example if you are on Mac OS you will
get a DMG image
and if you're on Linux you will get a
tar file so I am on Windows and I want
to download the exe installer and not
the zip on so I will select exe and then
hit download
now the IDE is a bit larger than the jdk
in size around at six four nine
megabytes but again depending on your
internet connection it may take a few
minutes to download Once you have
downloaded the software please go ahead
and install it like any other software
that you have done before
congratulations on your getting the jdk
and IntelliJ IDEA getting installed next
up you will need an account at mongodb
Atlas
now you may or may not already know that
mongodb Atlas is a platform from mongodb
themselves that allows you to spin up
mongodb servers
on the cloud
so in order to use mongodb Atlas you
will have to navigate to mongodb.com
Atlas slash database again the link will
be in description and use the sign in
button
once in the sign in page you can either
use your Google or GitHub account to log
in or you can sign up with your other
email addresses for a new account now I
already have an account on mongodb Atlas
so I will just use those credentials to
log into my account off screen as you
can see I have successfully logged into
my account and for first time users you
may have to set up a new organization of
sort just just put any name as the
organization name and you should be good
to go since we are using this for just
our development purposes it's it's okay
to just use any data that you have
so once you have set up your
organization you can create new projects
so I will hit the new project button
here
and I'll have to give my project a name
now since you are creating an API that
is related to movie I'll just call my
movie API and hit next
I will just go ahead and create projects
since I don't have any other member to
add
extra now we are inside our movie API
project and we are ready to create a new
database
so you can use the build database button
here to create a new mongodb database on
mongodb at class so just go ahead and
click this button
and there are three different categories
there is serverless there is dedicated
and there is share
now for development purposes a shared
server should be fine and it's
completely free but if you are working
on an application that
that has some user and have some real
live usage you may go with dedicated
serverless is something else and maybe
we can talk about it in a different
course another day
so select share and hit create
okay next up they will ask you about
which provider you want to use I always
go with AWS since AWS has a server on
Mumbai which is near Bangladesh and has
the lowest pin for me but if you like
you can go with Google cloud or azure
now select whatever region is the
nearest to you to make sure that you are
getting the lowest amount of ping
possible
next uh you can choose a tier
again for free usage we will use the m0
sandbox here it will give us
512 megabytes of ram which is more than
enough for our usage we will have a very
small amount of data to be honest
and then next up there are additional
settings we don't have to touch them and
the cluster name now you can customize
the cluster name if you wish but I will
just leave it as cluster 0 since I like
it that way
then hit create cluster
okay next up you will have to create a
new user for this uh cluster you can
also use an SSH certificate but I will
just go with the
old and trusty username thing so I will
name my username Solid Snake since I'm a
metal gear solid fan but you can name it
anything you want
now when it comes to password make sure
you are always choosing a very strong
password and not ones that are easy to
remember use a password manager maybe
but always use hard to guess passwords
so I will just use the auto generate
secure password
and I will also make sure that I am
copying my password to the clipboard
since I will be needing this later on
okay then hit the create user button
yeah it shows Solid Snake and the
password
and finally you will have to set up some
IP access list
so the way it works once you have set up
a new database you will have to allow a
set number of IP addresses that can
access that server
you know opening up a database server to
the world is not a good idea uh security
wise so you should always use your
current IP address here
but since this is just a course and we
are using this database for development
I will open up this server for all the
IP addresses out there and to do that
you can write
0.0.0.0 slash zero and in the
description you can just write
uh if you are
and hit add entry
see how that's there and then click on
finish and close
okay they will congratulate you and
whatnot hi quick start guide yes go to
database
let's close it
excellent now we have a database up and
running on mongodb Atlas and you can use
this database connect to it read and
write data from and to it
and use it just like a local database
that you may have used in your computers
you see mongodb Atlas is a very
beautiful service I have used it for
development as well as for protection in
the past and I have
never had any bad experiences with it
so next up you can use some sort of
database client to connect to these
database maybe something like mongodb
Compass so you can go ahead and click on
connect
and mongodb will give you multiple
options that you can choose from so
first step you can connect to your
database server using mongodb shell you
can connect to the mongodb server using
your application that you are working on
right now you can connect to mongodb
server using mongodb Compass which is
mongodb's own graphical user interface
for working with databases and I will
just show you that
finally you can also Connect using vs
code
now let's speak Connect using mongodb
Compass for now
and I do not have mongodb compass on my
computer
so I will pick windows 64 bit
and I will just hit download compass
once you have downloaded and installed
mongodb compass on your computer you can
start the software from your start menu
or desktop
once you start mongodb Compass it looks
something like this where they are
giving you the option to connect to a
new
database by using this kind of URI
now where do you get this URI
if you come back to mongodb Atlas you
will see that they are actually giving
the URI right here
just use this copy button to copy the
entire URI and go back to mongodb
Compass
now remove this localhost URI from here
and paste it yours
now as you can see it says mongodb plus
asrv then your username followed by a
colon and then it's looking for a
password right
so what we are going to do we will use
the password that we created earlier and
paste it in here and then we leave
everything as is and we can say save and
connect
you can name it anything so I'm naming
it movie API
you can change its color if you want to
and say save and connect
okay so it took a few seconds and as you
can see we have successfully connected
to our movie API cluster now as you can
see there are two databases one of them
is called admin and the other one is
called local now we do not have to do
anything with these these come by
default with all the Clusters out there
so just leave them be and we will create
new databases very soon to create a new
database you can always go and click
this plus sign
and inside database name
let's put maybe
um
battery
let's call it movie
API div
and inside collection name now if you
are new to databases like like mongodb
or document based database
you may or may not know that
collections are like tables in case of
relational database systems so in
something like MySQL or Oracle database
system you have databases and inside
those databases you have tables
now in case of mongodb and other
non-relational databases you have the
database name first and then collections
for example in our cases we will have a
collection of movies where we will save
information about different movies
so we can say
movies and
Eatery database
so as you can see we have a new database
sitting here movie API DV and there is a
collection called movies so right now
there is no
data at all
now in order to work with our API it
would be convenient if we have a bunch
of data in our Collections and if you
navigate to github.com
fhsinchy which is my username and slash
movie is you will get the entire code
for this API already written and inside
that repository you will see a folder
that says underscore data now inside
this folder there is a Json file that
you can use as a source of data for the
collection we have just created so I
would suggest you go into this Json file
then select Raw
and then hit Ctrl s and save this Json
file somewhere on your computer
so once you have downloaded the file you
can then import it to your collection
to do so come back to mongodb Compass
and while you have the movies collection
selected
you can click on this import data button
or this add data button then select
import file and our format is Json
and we will select a file from our
downloads and movies.json
and you can also take a stop on errors
then hit import wait a few moment
hit done and foiler we have the
information of n different movies on our
database so as you can see
each of this movie is a document okay as
it as it says documents 10. so inside a
collection each of this movie are a
single document
and what do we have inside these
documents well we have an ID we have the
IMDb ID for this title push inputs
we have the release date which is a
string we have the link for a trailer on
YouTube then we have an array of genres
so this particular movie belongs to five
genres
then we have a link to our poster
we have linked to 10 backdrops that will
be later utilized in the front-end
application as you'll see
finally we have an empty array for
review IDs now this will come into play
later on in this course so just be
patient with me for now
okay so one thing that I'd like to
mention right here I am using the
tmdb.org API for these images now tmdb
is an excellent website and they provide
a free to use API for developers as long
as you are giving them credit so I do so
I will be using their API for for
showing the images so now that we have
created a new database on mongodb I
class we have set up a new collection we
have imported some data into it it's
time for us to start working on our API
code
now the first step to writing our API
using spring boot is to initialize it
first to do that navigate to
start.spring.io again links will be in
the description and let's start
initializing our project
first we will have to pick a programming
language which is going to Java in this
case but if you are familiar with groovy
or kotlin you may go with them then we
will have to pick up project Autumn
build automation tool and the
initializer supports both Gradle and
Maven which are not the most popular
build automation tool for Java I am
going with Maven simply because I have
more experience working with this than
credit
next up picking up the spring boot
version now 3.0.1 is the latest stable
version and we will be using that
throughout the course but if you would
like to try out some more bleeding edge
features you can use the snapshots once
you have become more familiar with the
framework
after that we will have to fill up the
project metadata
now the group is usually Written In
Reverse domain format so for example my
website is
farhan.dev and I would like to name my
group day dot for her so if you do not
have a domain of yourself you can name
it anything you like as long as
that package group is not referring to
someone else's project
next up the artifact name the artifact
name is simply the name of the project
so in this case I will be putting movies
in here but feel free to call it
something else if you feel like that
next there is a description field and
you can put something like
after that we will have to pick a
packaging format now jar is a very
popular packaging format for Java and it
stands for Java archive war on the other
hand stands for web archive and you may
think that well what is more suited for
this project since it's going to be a
web application right
maybe yes but since jar is more widely
used then what I will be going with jar
next picking the Java version obviously
I am going to pick 17 since we just
spent quite some time setting up Java 17
on our computers once you are done with
the left column let's focus on the right
column in this one you will
have to pick the dependencies that you
would like to use in your project so use
this add button and you will be
presented with a long very long list of
dependencies now the first one that we
are going to use in our project is
lombok it's an annotation library that
saves you from writing a lot of
boilerplate code and you will see what I
mean in action very soon so please be
patient
since we are going to pick multiple
dependencies you'll have to keep
pressing either control on Windows or
Linux and command on Mac
in fact it says here right on the right
corner press Ctrl to multiple apps okay
for multiple ads so I'm pressing down on
control and I will pick long block
lombok has been picked next up Spring
web
and finally
let's see
no not SQL under no SQL we will need
spring data mongodb yeah that's that's
pretty much it you can also search for
things here for example devtools and
let's add that as well once done you can
exit out of this selector by pressing
escape on your keyboard and have a look
at the list of dependencies and make
sure you have the everything
there are other dependencies that you
may learn about later on such as the
reactive wave
or graphql or race repositories or
something like maybe Spring Security
which can be used for authentication and
authorization there is oauth2 client if
you are into oauth and things like that
but since we will not be getting into
authentication and authorization in this
course we will stay away from them okay
once you are happy with the
configuration in this initializer tool
go ahead and click generate
it will take a few seconds to generate
the zip archive and it will start
downloading automatically
once downloaded you have to extract
these movies dot zip or whatever you
have named your artifact dot C5 to
somewhere in your computer easily
accessible
after you have extracted the downloaded
zip file somewhere on your computer you
can go ahead and open it in your
favorite IDE or code editor in my case
it's IntelliJ IDEA and I have extracted
my project on my D drive
so I will go ahead and click on open
first
then come to the folder where I have
extracted
the project
and I will pick it up
okay so IntelliJ IDEA will ask whether
you actually just this project or not
this is a safety feature to save you
from malicious code from running on your
computer so since we are writing it
ourself I just pick trust project
and give idea some time
for resolving all the dependencies and
once it's ready you are free to go
let's try to understand the project
structure first so ignore the dot mvn
folder it's managed by Maven so you
don't have to worry about it right now
there is the SRC folder which is short
for source and it will contain your
program source code as well as the text
codes we are not going to write any
tests so let's jump into the main folder
so inside main there is Java and
resources we will have to work inside
both of these directories so let's go
inside Java and as you can see here is
the name of our project f.400 movies it
it may be different
in your computer depends on what you
have chosen in the initializer but it
should be something similar
then there is a class that represents
your application's name so since I have
named my artifact movies it says movies
application
which is pretty appropriate to be honest
another movies application class
contains around 10 lines of code minus
the spaces in between so let's try to
understand what it's doing now the first
line is actually declaring a package
which
pretty self-explanatory next there are
two import statements the first one is a
class called Spring application
now this particular class contains a
method called run
and to start your spring application you
actually have to call this run method
and then pass your application class to
it
and then you can also pass some command
line arguments which we are not going to
touch
the second important statement Imports
the spring boot application annotation
so annotations in Java are usually used
to let the compiler know
about what this class does
so other than this class there is more
or less nothing inside this package so
let's try to run our application and see
if we can we can have anything on our
browser okay
so you can actually click on this play
button besides the main method to run
the program or this class play button or
display button at the top let's use this
one
okay so if your IDE says lombok requires
enabled annotation processing just go
ahead and click on enable annotation
processing and it should be fine
now if you look at the terminal you will
see that there is a nice art that says
spraying the Springs version and there
is bunch of logs and there is an
exception
the exception states that the
application is failing to connect to any
mongodb database at all which is true
since we have not let the application
know about our
our cluster our username
our passwords and things like that the
application cannot connect to our
mongodb database now it's fine if you
want to leave this error here or if you
want to get rid of this error
you can just first stop the application
open the pom.xml file
which contains a list of all the
different dependencies that we are using
and then look for
mongodb
it should be here somewhere yeah there
you go dependency artifact spring Booter
startup data mongodb so just highlight
the entire thing and press Ctrl
and then forward slash which will
comment this out
then right click on form.xml
and then go to maven
and go to reload project
now try to run the application once
again
yeah
know your whatsoever
so if you look at the logs it will say
that Tomcat started on port 8080 Tomcat
is actually an web server that will
serve as the web server the developed
web server for our application
now you'd have to switch to your web
browser to see the application in action
so let's do that
and then you can navigate to localhost
8.
8080
there we go now it says white level
error page that's fine at least we know
that the application is booting up and
we are actually hitting the API itself
and not just some other page
but what this error States is that there
is no end point at all so although we
have an API there is no API to it I hope
that makes sense now let's go back to
our code and try to write our first
endpoint
now after where it says the spring boot
application
we will say
rest controller
it's another annotation that lets
the framework note that this class is
actually a rest API controller and not
just another class
then inside this class you will have to
say
get mapping
and next you will have to create a new
method called public and the return type
will be string and the name of the
method can be anything but let's just
call it API index for now because this
is the
root endpoint or or List let's call it
API root
yeah
and we can say return
hello Earth
I know howward programs are boring but
it's essential you know
so this gate mapping annotation which
what it does is that it lets that
framework know that this method right
here API root is a get endpoint so if I
put a bracket right here and then inside
I'll say slash Justified slash
let's stop our application
and run it again
let's see if there are any errors
looks fine to me let's switch to our web
browser
and we refresh as you can see it says
hello world app let me just increase the
zoom level a bit so you can yeah hello
world
now instead of putting a forward slash
share if I say it for say slash root
rerun the application
you will see that the white label error
page is back but if you navigate to
slash root you will see Hello World
I hope this makes sense although this is
a valid endpoint we are not going to
make our API like this we will actually
divide our application into separate
layers there will be a service layer
there will be a data access layer and
there will be an API layer so let's go
forward and get rid of this code and
start to put together our movies API
now
in my opinion the first logical step
would be to configure the database for
our application so that we can
successfully connect to the mongodb
cluster that we have set up previously
and talk to it
to do so open up the SRC folder right
here
go inside Main
go inside resources
and open the file that says
application.properties
now in this file you will have to write
the different application properties
that is related to your project
now for example right now we are trying
to configure our mongodb dependency
and to do that you will have to write
spring Dot data
Dot mongodb
dot database
equals to the name of the database I
hope you remembered that we named our
database something like
movies API DB so we will write movies
API DB
and next
spring
dot data Dot mongodb
dot URI
now in here you will have to actually
write the URI to your mongodb cluster
like you did with compass
I have my URI already copied to my
clipboard and I hope that you have saved
it somewhere safe like I said in the
beginning of the course so I'll just go
ahead and paste it right there
and you can get rid of the slash test
thing and the last slash and it should
be fine okay so
our application should be able to
connect to our database now to test it
out let's go back to Bomb Dot XML let's
remove the comments
and then let's start our application and
oh
see we have forgot to reload our project
and the IDE is actually suggested
me to load them having changes so I can
just click this button or you can go
ahead and right click then go to Maven
and reload project
let's use this button and see if it
works fine or not
of course it does let's run the
application
and now the error is gone and actually
it says some things about the mongodb
driver cluster and this is a positive
sign if it fail to connect to the
database itself it would have
screamed at us and whatnot but
thankfully it's fine
now if you have worked with any
applications specifically web
applications in the past you may already
know that putting sensitive data like
this in a file that's going to be in
your GitHub repository is not safe at
all
instead what you should be doing is
putting all these things in a DOT EnV
file so we can right click on resource
go to new and create a DOT EnV file for
ourselves
and we can write down a few properties
here
[ __ ] database
then [ __ ] user
10 [ __ ]
password
finally [ __ ]
cluster
now you can go back to the properties
file and you can start moving these
values one by one to your EnV file so
this is going to be the [ __ ] database
next up the mongook username which is
solid snake in my case
then [ __ ] password
finally the cluster
and I sometimes
like to put them inside quotes please
make sure that if one of the passwords
or username or clusters contains some
special characters in them it would not
disturb
the order of things so I would like to
put
this
quotation marks around each values
okay now we have our EnV file ready to
go what I would suggest that you create
another EnV file
simply called dot Envy Dot example
for letter references
nice
then make sure you open up the dot git
ignore file and as you can see the
initialize project actually comes with a
pretty good git ignore file already but
we'll have to add a few things for
ourselves right
so you'll say you can actually copy this
thing from here and paste it and say
in v y
EP
and then you say dot PNP this will make
sure that you do not accidentally commit
the dot EnV file into your repository
and open up your database to the world
now the only problem with this spring is
that spring doesn't support
reading.anv files out of the box
so what we will need is we actually
need to install
a new dependency to our project and I
would like to take this opportunity to
show you how you can add new
dependencies to the project later on so
I'll switch back to my
browser
I'll open up a new tab and I will search
for
uh
maven
dependencies something like that yeah
and here is Maven Repository
then let's search for something along
the line spring
dot EnV
yeah I am referring to this one by Paul
Suarez I apologize if I have pronounced
his name wrong
let's
select this one and we can see that it
says the spring plugins 1.0 and it says
Central and what not okay so the name of
the thing is me.paulshore S Spring dot
EnV so as you can guess this is his crew
group name and this is the name of the
artifact or the or the project itself so
we can go back to our code let's open up
com.xml
and inside the dependencies part make
sure you are inside dependencies are not
outside somewhere here
after the last dependency
we will create a new one
so it's a dependency
and the IDE helps us by Auto completing
this and we will say that the group ID
is me Dot
all
s c h
w a r c just to make sure you can always
copy it from here
no one's going to judge you for that
and then name of the artifact which is
is spring dot EnV
now it's not strictly necessary to
define a version as well but you can do
so by saying
version
and then put maybe the latest one 2.5.4
yeah
so that's it let's reload maven
and here now our project has the ability
to use the spring.nv artifact and
read.mp files
let's go back to our application
properties and replace these hard-coded
values with our DOT EMV references
to do so open up the resources and we
will need the EnV so [ __ ] database
[ __ ] user [ __ ] password okay
so you will first
have to get rid of this value and then
start with the dollar sign
and curly braces and inside the set of
curly braces you will see say EnV Dot
[ __ ]
what did I call it database
yeah [ __ ] database
and you can kind of copy it from here
then
you'll replace Solid Snake by [ __ ] user
excellent then this should be [ __ ]
password
password tricked
yes and finally a cluster
mango cluster yes what does this mean
okay we can ignore this typo and if you
once in a while you can actually come to
this problems Tab and have a look at
what are what's the ID is complaining
about so the unused property let's just
ignore them from now
which one is oh yeah yeah okay let's
ignore this for now and the typos okay
[ __ ] is not a typo
except let's try running our application
once again and see if our EnV file has
taken any effect or not
so as it turns out our mongodb
connection is fine which means the EnV
file has been read successfully and we
have successfully secured our
confidential information from going out
into the world
now you you don't have to write
everything inside a EnV file you can
actually use this EnV dot name of the
variable notation to access any
environment variable in your operating
system so I'll not get into that anymore
since we don't need it let's go ahead
and get along with our project
now in our application there are two
types of data that we are going to work
with first there are the movies and then
there are the reviews
so we will need to First create two
separate classes for representing these
two entities in our application
so first let
left click on your project name new and
Java class let's call it movie
and inside this movie we will first have
to annotate this class as a document
this will let the framework know that
this class she presents each document in
the movies collection
and we will also Define the name of the
collection here movies
then inside here we will have
a bunch of private data so private
object id id this will represent the ID
of this movie
then private
IMDb ID sorry
string
IMDb ID
which will represent the IMDb ID of this
movie
then private
string title
private string
release date
private
string
shadler link this will be a link to the
YouTube page for the trailer
private string poster a link to the
image on the internet
private list
string
this would be the genres because there
can be multiple genres of a single movie
and this list class need to be imported
yeah Java you did
finally private list
string
and
this will be the backdrops now these
backdrop images will actually be used in
the front-end application as you will
see later let's just quickly jump to
mongodb
compass and make sure that we have
indeed written all the necessary
properties for this class
so as you can see we have written ID
IMDb ID title yes release date trailer
link genres poster backdrops and review
ID so you we will add review IDs a few
moments later
now
we'll have to also annotate this ID
field
and
as an actual ID
this will live
the framework know that
this property should be treated as the
unique identifier for each movie Inside
the database
okay apart from this we will also need
getter Setters and two string Methods
and some Constructors so instead of
writing out guitar Setters to string for
each of these private properties we can
just say
at the rate data and this is one of the
annotations that comes from the lombok
project and it takes care of all those
different Gator Setters and two string
Methods
next we will also add
all args Constructor this is basically
annotation for creating a Constructor
that takes all this private field as
argument finally no args Constructor
which means another Constructor that
takes
no
parameters whatsoever
okay next let's create the reviews so
Java class
review
it's the same deal
so this will be document
and the collection name will be refused
now we haven't created this collection
yet but
the application itself has the ability
to create new collections so we don't
have to worry about that we'll add data
just like before
all
RX Constructor
noise Constructor and then
there will be two private properties
first one private
object ID
this would be the ID in this case
and then
private
review body
just just body
string and body
okay so as you may have already seen in
the database design that each of these
movies has an array of this review and
we haven't yet added this this area of
reviews to the movie model yet so to do
that we'll go back to the movie class
come near the end and say
private
list
review
IDs okay so it matches this name review
IDs
and yeah all the other names are
matching elsewhere yes now if you write
it like this this will be an embedded
relationship so all the reviews that are
related this movie will be added to this
list of reviews now this is completely
fine in fact if you are modeling a
one-to-many relationship such as one
movie can have many reviews this is the
way to go
but since I am trying to demonstrate
some of the features of a spring boot
mongodb data I will show you a Nifty
annotation right here so I will say
document reference
so this will cause the database to
restore only the IDS of the review and
the reviews will be in a separate
collection so this is called
manual reference relationship and there
are some other ways to create
relationships in mongodb I would suggest
that you search them up on Google or
mongodb's official documentation and
read about them on your leisure it will
give you a lot of context
so now that we have our movie and review
models ready to go we can go ahead and
start writing our controllers so I will
right click on
my package then a Java class
this will be called movie
controller
and this is our first official rest API
controller that we are writing in this
API previously we wrote a simple
controller in our movies application
class but this time it's going to be a
bit different
so first we will need to annotate this
class as a rest controller
and instead of mapping it to localhost
8080
I want to make it sorry
mapping request mapping
I want to make it map to slash API slash
V1 slash movies
so any request to slash API slash V1
movies endpoint will be handled by this
particular controller
next I will create a new get method
so I will say get mapping
and then
public
let's return string for now
um all movies
and then we can return
all movies
okay let's try to run our program and
see if it works or not let's hit the
play button
foreign
[Music]
let's go back to our browser
and here localhost 8080 slash root
we will get rid of fruit and say slash
API slash V1
slash movies
and it works
now although it's okay to return his
strings from this end point it's better
to return
a response
entity I'll show you why in a minute
so this is a generic type so we'll say
string
and then instead of returning or
returning
and instead of returning all movies like
this we will say
new response entity of type is string
and this is the value
then HTTP status dot okay
HTTP status dot OK means 200
let's rerun this program
refresh
and it works just as expected now you
may not see any difference here but if
you go back to your terminal
and say
Carl
I HTTP localhost 8080 slash API slash
View and slash movies you will see we
are indeed returning the 200 Response
Code
this comes in handy when working on a
front-end application and any rest API
out there should return proper status
codes
since we have the movie model right here
let's try to use it and pull some data
from the database
for that we will need a service class as
well as a repository class so let's
create the repository first because
that's the shorter one so it's a Java
class and we'll select interface because
repositories are of type interface
and then we'll say movie in Repository
yeah now this interface will extend
[ __ ] Repository
this is the generic type and
we will have to let it know what type of
data we are dealing with so movie and we
will also need to let it know what type
of ID we are dealing with which will be
objects
ID
there you go
that's all for this interface you will
need to annotate this interface as a
repository so the framework knows that
this is a repository
and then let's create a service class
which will be
movie service
in this class will not extend anything
you will just need to annotate as
service
now inside this class we will write the
database access methods so the first one
will be public
uh get all movies
but let's just name it all movies
and let's just change our controller
method name to
get all movies because since it's a git
mapping we are saying get all movies
and the return type will be
list
of it will return a list of movie from
this method
now inside this service class you will
need a reference of the repository to do
that you will say
movie Repository
it will be a private field
and its name will be movie Repository
now if you know Java you may know that
you will have to first initialize this
bit of code you will either have to
initialize it using a Constructor or you
can just use
Auto wire
annotation what this will cause it will
let the framework know that we want the
framework to instantiate this class here
for us okay
let's go inside the method now and we
will say return
movie repository dot find all
now this find all method is described
inside the [ __ ] repository class
as you can see it says right here find
all and it will return and list of the
data type that we have passed right here
so early stop moving
so that's our service class right there
and then let's go back to our controller
we will need a reference to our service
class
so we will say private
movie service
movie service and just like we did in
the service class we will Auto wire this
service class since it has the service
annotation right here
we'll say Auto wired
excellent and it's all set
now inside the get all movies
instead of returning a response entity
of type string
change it to list
movie
so we are returning a response entity of
type list movie
then inside the method we will have to
write
return
movie service
Dot
all movies
new response entity
of type list
movie
and inside movie service dot all movies
comma
HTTP status dot ok
yeah let's take a look at our repository
once again yeah it's all setup
service is fine the controller is fine
let's cross our finger and see
if this works or not
foreign
now the reason behind this problem
lies in my EnV file
so as you can see
we have called our database movie API DB
but in our configuration we mistakenly
put an S right here so you'll get rid of
the s
restart the application and hope for the
best
and yeah it works as you can see there
are 10 movies in this list since it
starts at zero and ends at nine there
are 10 movies in this list and the code
is perfectly fine now let's go back to
the code and let me reiterate on what
you have done so far so in rest apis
usually there are multiple
layers
so one of the layers is the API layer
which is this controller and it will
only concern itself about the task of
getting a request from the user and
returning a response and nothing else
and that's what it's doing all it's
doing is it's using a service class and
delegating the task of fetching all the
movies from the database and
give me giving it back to the API layer
so it calls
the all movies method inside
the service
gets the list of the movie and returns
them with HTTP status okay it doesn't
know what's going on inside the surface
class
now when you come back to the service
class this is where most of our business
logic will go
for now there is nothing
to be worried about in these classes but
soon we will work with a little bit more
complex business Logics in this API
so this service class does is it uses
the repository class and talks to the
database get the list of the movies and
returns to the API layer
finally the repository layer is kind of
the data access layer for our API it
does the job of actually talking to the
database and getting the data back
I hope that makes sense
now since we have a list of all the
movies in our databases
let's complicate it a bit more by trying
to access a single movie
now we will begin
by creating a new gate mapping
and that is
get mapping and this will actually take
an parameter
and we will have to say slash then
inside a pair of curly braces we will
say ID so we are trying to search a
movie by its ID
so we can say public
response entity
this time we will return a single movie
and we'll say get
single
movie sorry for the typo
we'll close
the pair of parentheses
and start our method
now inside the pair of parentheses we
will have to say
but variable which lets the framework
know that we will be passing the
information we got in the mapping as a
path variable
or we will be using the information
passed in the path variable
as a string
or just object
ID
ID
so what this does is it lets the
framework know that whatever you are
getting through this path variable we
want to convert that to an object ID
called ID
and then we can say
return
now first we will have to go back to our
service layer and write a new method
here
public
movie
single movie
and we'll say return
movie repository Dot
find by
ID
and we will get that ID right here
and it goes here ID
save it and this quickly line it says
that returns generator option okay
so the thing here is that the find by ID
method may not find any movie at all
maybe the ID you have passed doesn't
exist
so in those case you it will have to
return null so we will have to let Java
know that it may return null by saying
optional
movie
and we will just import the optional
class
we will also have to fix our response
Entity movie we will say optional
movie
optional has been imported nice
and then we can say return
new response entity
are optional
movie
and inside there we can say movie
service
dot single movie we will pass the ID
that we have received comma
HTTP status dot ok
but let's restart the application
let's go to our mongodb compass
inside the movie collection and copy one
of the object IDs right here let's copy
for roll dolls Matilda the Musical
let's copy the object ID
go back to our browser
and you can say movies
slash and then the object ID
okay as you can see we have found Roald
Dahl's Matilda the Musical
now the problem is that I do not want to
expose the object IDs of my collection
entities to the public instead what I
want to do is use this IMDb ID
to search for new movies
so let's see if we can find a way to do
that
now although the repository comes with
built-in methods for searching with ID
it doesn't come with methods for
searching with IMDb ID so what we will
have to do is we will have to implement
that method ourselves
and it's really easy because
there is something called automatic
queries that lets you
form where is dynamically from
property names
so we will say optional
movie because it may return null once
again will have to import optional
movie and we will call it
find
movie
by
indp
i d and it takes a string
IMDb ID
now just by naming this method find
movie by IMDb ID
mongodb data spring data mongodb will
understand what we are trying to do it's
it's that much intelligent
so now we can go back to our service
class
we are no longer getting an object ID
but we are getting a string
IMDb ID
and instead of find by ID we will say
find movie by IMDb ID
IMDb ID
and that's it
let's go back to controller
we'll change this from ID to IMDb ID by
the way you do not have to name the ID
IMDb ID exactly in this methods it's
it's just that I know what I am doing in
a later date so we will replace object
ID by string
IMDb ID
and then response entity optional movie
yeah this is fine yeah IMDb
so technically this should do our job
let's check it out
it seems like there has been a mistake
let's go up
foreign looks like there's a problem
let's go back to
our movie Repository
and the mistake is it should be IMDb and
not IMBD so as you can see
the framework is clever enough to see
that I have misspelled
the property name right here
so let's run the program once again and
see if it runs or not
find who Babe cannot find
up here I have to correct here as well
dear
and yeah it should be fine now
let's go back to our browser and as you
can see API movies and then I have used
the IMDb ID for this movie
hit enter and if it works just fine we
can use the IMDb ID to search for movies
now now you can actually form Dynamic
queries like this using any property
name in your model class
as long as they're unique because if
that's not unique you will get multiple
movies with the same ID or same name
okay
now that we have our movie controller
sorted out let's start working on our
review controller where we will let the
user send us review
and we will add those under a movie name
so let's first create a new Repository
review
Repository
and it
tends mongodb
[ __ ] repository and the type will be
reviewed
and object ID is our type of file yeah
yeah that's
there
next let's create a new service class oh
oh I almost forget to enter this as
Repository
create a new class called
review service
and this will be a service class so I
will go service
here I will say public
then
this method will create a new review so
it will return a new review then create
review
bye
then this method will take two
parameters the first one will be a
string
which will be the review for the
and doesn't
the second one will be string
IMDb ID so what we are trying to do here
we will first
look for the movie with the given IMDb
ID and then we will create a new review
and Associate that review with the found
movie
so let's first create a new review
0 equals new review
now you may
now you may remember that in the review
class we have an all Arts Constructor
and an orx Constructor but since IDs are
Auto generated we cannot pass an ID to
this class so what we will do we will
also generate a custom Constructor that
takes only the body
now in intelligent idea you can right
click inside a class go to generate and
then Constructor and we only need the
body part of this class
so that's there
now let's go back to our service class
and new review and we will pass the
review body
excellent
now that we have a new review we will
have to associate these to one of the
movies
now that we have a new review object we
will have to insert it to the database
and for that we will need
a reference to our
review Repository
so review repository review repository
and it needs to be ordered
fine and we will say
review Repository
dot insert
and review
excellent that's the review taken care
of now we will have to associate with
this with one of the movies right
to do that we will
need a few things now the first thing
that we need is called
a template to create a template we'll
say private
[ __ ] template
[ __ ] template now you have already
learned about repositories as one of the
ways to talk to the database the other
way is using a template
you see there are times when a
repository just doesn't cut it maybe you
have an operation so complex that it
cannot be implemented within a
repository or even if you can implement
it within a repository it will
be not
suitable
so what we need we need
template you can use this template to
form up a new Dynamic query and do the
job inside the database without using
the repository so we will Auto add this
and then down here we will say
[ __ ] template
dot update since it's an update
operation and we will need to say which
class do you do we want to update so we
want to update one of the movies
and then come to the second line and put
a dot here and then as you can see there
are multiple operations that we can
perform so we want the matching
now inside the matching up version we
will need a new criteria
so we'll say criteria
dot where
and inside where you will say IMDb ID
make sure it's matching up with the
column name or the property name inside
the database
then dot is
the IMDb ID that we have got
then come to the next line and put a dot
once again and then we will say apply
we'll say new update this is called an
update definition
dot push
review IDs
and then Dot
value
review
see that that's pretty much it okay so
what we are doing is we are using the
template to perform an update call on
the movie class because I hope that you
remember that each movie in our
collection contains an empty array of
review IDs so what we need to do
what we need to do is we need to update
this array and push a new review ID into
this
so we are saying movie dot class then we
have to perform the matching so which
movie are we updating we are updating a
movie where the IMDb ID of the movie in
the database matches the IMDb ID that we
have received from the user okay then we
want to apply the subject to do so we
call apply
and then we create a new update
definition which does the job of making
the change inside the database
so we say update.push
review IDs
so we want to update the review IDs in
this found movie and the value of this
movie will be reviewed so the review
that we have just created it will be
pushed inside the review IDs array okay
now
finally we will have to say dot first
to make sure that we are getting a
single movie and we are updating that
now one thing that I have done which I
shouldn't have is we cannot new up a
review like this
rather what we need to do is we will
just
save the review on insert because when
you call insert it actually Returns the
data you just
pushed inside your database okay
here first finally we can return
that if you we just created
so let's review the create review method
we are taking a new [ __ ] template we
are using it to update the movie with a
new review we just pushed using the
Repository
so like I said sometimes you will have
to code up complex business Logics by
yourself and as you grow as a software
engineer and an web developer you will
start to understand all these things all
by yourself
so let's go back to our review service
yeah sorry I mean our review
plus is fine if you Repose transfer
review service yeah now let's create a
new review controller
and inside this controller we will have
only one post method
like you may think why only a single
Postman account how are we going to get
all these reviews that are associated
with the movie I'll show you how
now let's begin by annotating it as a
rest controller
and then of course we will have to input
request mapping
which is
slash API slash V1 slash
movies
okay since uh
the review form will be inside a movie's
Details page or in the page where you
are viewing a single movie so we can
make the request to the movies endpoint
instead of creating a new reviews in
input now when it comes to creating
endpoints like this it it really depends
on the on the developer's preferences he
may you may
choose to organize your API differently
from what I am doing here and
in a real life project I maybe I will do
something different but since it's just
for Learning and we are just getting
started I think it's fine
now inside the controller we will first
need our service so we'll say private
review service
review service and we will Auto add this
nice
then we will create a new post mapping
thank you
and then a new method public
in return a response entity and this
will be of type review
and we will call it create review method
now inside this pair of parentheses we
will say
request body
then map
string comments
and we will call it payload
swim import map
so what we are saying to the framework
here that whatever we get as the request
body we would like to convert it to a
map of
the key string and value string and we
want to name this map as payload you
will see why this is
then we will say
return new response entity
and here we can say review obviously
review
and then we use the service
review service dot create review and we
will pass
two things first one payload dot get
is the review body
and the second one would be payload dot
get
IMDb ID
okay
finally we say
comma
http
status dot created it will be 201 since
we are creating a new review we want to
send 201 instead of the plane 200
because this means created and that
means okay
so now that we have the post mapping
done we need a rest client a separate
risk client to test our test out our
code but before that I can see that
there is this quickly line under major
view controller so I will just go to
problems and see what's wrong
cannot resolve Symbol IMDb ID okay let's
see where I miss the type of yeah it
should be inside a pair of quotation
mark and that's gone see this is the
beauty of IntelliJ IDEA it helps you a
lot
now let's restart our program and I will
use Postman to test out our API
in fact I just thought instead of
mapping the reviews request to API slide
P1 movies let's just go with reviews
because that sounds more appropriate
now let's start our application
foreign
[Music]
so inside Postman first I will create a
new collection and I'll call it movies
API
then let's create a new get request get
all movies
so it will be localhost 8080 slash API
slash P1 slash
of x
so it works out just fine let's copy
the IMDb ID from one of these movies so
that we can test out our next request
which will be
get a single movie
and we should be able to carry
everything from the previous request
can host slash V1 slash movie slash then
the IMDb ID
let's execute and yeah it works just
fine
finally
let's
try to create a new review
[Music]
and we'll say V1 slash reviews
okay that that's
I set the request by mistake so it has
to be paused now inside body I use the
raw data in Json format
so I will say
review
body
will be I really enjoyed
the movie with
yeah
and then I will say IMDb ID
ID now you have to make sure that the
name
or the key in this Json data review body
and IMDb ID
exactly matches
the two keys inside the payload which is
review body and IMDb ID so what will
happen is this endpoint will receive a
Json data from the user and then convert
it to a map where the keys are string
and the values are extreme then from
this map we will be able to access the
review body which is a string and the
IMDb ID which is another string
and then through the service layer we
can create a new review on the database
update the movie to be associated with
that review and then return the review
and of course there's a repository that
works as the intermediary layer
between the service class and the
database let's let's go
let's come back to PostNet and let's see
if it actually works or not
yes so we have got 201 created so
theoretically we should have created a
new review for the movie Puss in Boots
now let's go back to get a single movie
hit send
come down to review IDs and of course we
have the new review associated with this
movie
now that's how we can get the list of
review IDs they will be embedded with
the data of the movie they are referred
to
so in terms of the API that's it I know
it's a pretty simple API but the goal of
this course or the first half of this
course was to give you some idea about
how you can create a new backend API
powered by Spring Boot and mongodb I
hope that you have understood the basic
concepts around using mongodb and spring
boot together you can go ahead and
further your study by learning about how
to implement authorization and
authentication you can also learn about
more complex relationships and maybe try
to build a bigger API with deletes and
puts and other kind of requests
I will be leaving this stretch right now
and from now on Gavin long will teach
you how you can create a react
application that can go with this API
so take care I will maybe see you in
another course in the future
now that you've learned how to develop
the back end Gavin will teach you how to
develop the front end using react
just a quick note before we get started
this will not be a deep dive into react
my only goal here is to demonstrate how
we can interface with a remote API from
a front-end application created using
react through which we are able to
retrieve data from a mongodb database
hosted on a remote server as well as
post data to our mongodb database
now any data that we retrieve from the
server will be in Json format
Json formatted data may be pleasing to
some people
but most users of our application I
think would much prefer something like
this
so we're going to transform the data
passed to us in a Json format into an
aesthetically pleasing front-end display
react and Associated Technologies
provide an efficient way to create both
aesthetically pleasing front ends as
well as help us developers to facilitate
a great ux user experience I'd like to
give a shout out to the moviedb.org all
the movie poster images and backdrop
images that we are going to use in the
react application that we are going to
build in this course come from the
moviedb.org right let's get into it
let's start by launching vs code
and let's create a working folder on our
local machines
I'm going to name my folder
movie client
let's open our working folder like this
from within vs code
so we are going to use the create Dash
react Dash app command to generate our
react projects infrastructure you of
course must have node.js preferably the
latest version installed on your local
machine as a prerequisite before
creating a react application
if you don't have node.js installed you
can navigate to this URL to install the
latest release of mode Js
so from within vs code let's launch the
terminal window so that we can create
our react project infrastructure using
the create Dash react Dash app command
you can launch the terminal window from
within vs code by pressing Ctrl and the
tilde character
great
so the current directory reflected at
the terminal prompt should be the
working directory that we have just
created my working directory is named
movie client
then at the terminal prompt let's type
in npx space create Dash react Dash app
followed by the name we would like to
call our react project
so I'm going to name my react project
movie Dash gold Dash V1
then let's press the enter key
and for create Dash react Dash app
command generates the react project
infrastructure which includes all the
relevant node modules that contain
components that we are able to import
into our react application
this process can take a while to
complete
and we can see the process on my local
machine has now completed
so at this stage we don't really need
the movie client folder opened within vs
code we only want the folder containing
the files for our react project so at
the terminal let's use the CD command
and then enter the name of the react
application that we created using Create
Dash react Dash app
so I'm going to type CD Space movie Dash
gold Dash V1 and press the enter key
so once we have made the folder
containing the files for our react
projects infrastructure we can launch
another instance of vs code by typing in
code space Dot and then pressing the
enter key
this command opens another instance of
vs code where we are now directly within
the folder that contains the files for
our react projects infrastructure
we can now close down the first instance
of vs code because we only need the
instance that we have just launched
so we are almost ready to create our
react application
we won't be using some of the files that
the create-react app command generated
for us so let's delete the following
files from within the SRC directory
let's delete the
setuptests.js file the report vitals.js
file and the
app.test.js file
foreign
we must also delete a setting from
within the package.json file which is to
do with linting
we don't need this linting setting in
our project
let's save our changes
lastly let's open the index.js file and
remove the code related to the report
web vitals functionality like this
let's save our changes
and let's move on to installing a few
npm packages that contain components
that we are going to integrate into our
application
if your project terminal is not
available within vs code at the moment
you are able to launch the terminal by
pressing Ctrl and the tilde character
the next package we are going to install
is axios axios will make it easy for us
to make HTTP requests from our react
client to the relevant API hosted on a
distant remote machine
so that we can retrieve relevant movie
data from the mongodb database also
hosted on the relevant distant remote
machine through HTTP get requests
we will also be able to add movie
reviews to the relevant mongodb database
through the use of HTTP post requests
which will be facilitated on our react
client through the use of axios
we'll implement this functionality later
in this video
so to install axios we can type this
command at the command prompt
npm space install space axios
and let's press the enter key
great so let's install our next npm
package
which will enable us to use bootstrap
for layout and styling purposes from
within our react project so let's type
the following at our command prompts
npm space install space bootstrap
note that in order to integrate
bootstrap into our project we must
include this import statement within the
index.js file
let's save our changes
the next npm package that we must
install allows us to use bootstrap
related components for layout and
styling purposes
so let's install react Dash bootstrap
for this purpose
we can install react Dash bootstrap by
typing npm space i space react Dash
bootstrap
and of course follow this by pressing
the enter key
great
the next npm package that we are going
to install enables us to easily install
font awesome icons
within our react application the first
font awesome related package can be
installed by typing in npm space i space
at Fort awesome forward slash react Dash
font awesome
so make sure you type at Fort awesome
here and not at font Dash awesome which
I know is a little bit confusing
so it's at Fort awesome Dash react Dash
and then font awesome
great
let's install the second font awesome
related package by typing in npm space i
space at Fort awesome
forward slash free Dash solid Dash SVG
Dash icons
and let's of course press the enter key
excellent
to play movie trailers from within our
application
we're going to use the react player
component so let's install the
appropriate npm package so that we can
integrate react player into our react
application so let's type npm space i
space react dash player
and press the enter key
great
in order to declare the paths where our
components will reside in order to map
The Roots to our components as it were
we are going to use relevant components
from the react Dash router Dash Dom npm
package so in order to install the react
Dash router Dash Dom npm package let's
type in this command npm space i space
react Dash router Dash Dom
and of course press the enter key
great
on our home page we want to display
relevant movies in a carousel
we can easily Implement a carousel using
material UI so in order to do this we
must install three material UI npm
packages
so we can install the relevant three npm
packages by typing the following npm
space install space at mui forward slash
material space at emotion forward slash
react space at emotion forward slash
styles
and let's press the enter key
excellent
in order to use the material UI Carousel
component let's install the material UI
Carousel npm package
we can do this by typing in npm
space install space react Dash material
Dash UI Dash carousel
and press the enter key
great
and we have now installed all the npm
packages we need in order to integrate
the functionality we want to include
within our react application
excellent
let's get started with writing the code
for our react application so the first
thing I'd like to do is set up axios
so to do this let's create a folder
within the SRC folder
and let's name our folder API
let's create a file within the API
folder named axiosconfig.js
we can import axios into our project
with this line of code
so we can configure and Export the axios
object that we'll use to make HTTP
requests to the relevant remote API
through this code
note the settings that have been
included here
we have the base URL setting which
provides the Base address of the API
endpoints that our client react
application will be calling
so you'll see later on when we use axios
to call an endpoint
we won't need to repeat the base URL
with each HTTP request within our code
we'll only need to include the
additional path information required to
Target a specific endpoint
if this isn't clear at the moment it
will become clear
when we write code to make a HTTP
request to the relevant remote endpoint
this setting here is necessary because
during the development phase the
technology that the remote machine is
using to expose the relevant API
endpoints is called ngrok
I won't go into the specifics of ngruck
but we need to include this setting in
order for our client HTTP requests to
not be blocked by cores I won't go into
the details of course but it stands for
cross-origin resource sharing so all we
need to know is that because the
relevant web API is running in a
different domain
or origin that Course May block our
access to the end point
the server code has included settings in
order to overcome the restrictions
imposed by cause
and we are including this setting in the
HTTP headers of our requests from the
client so that we can overcome the
restrictions imposed by cause I.E
so that we are able to access the
resources made available through the
relevant API endpoints
great so we have now set up axios
let's open the app.js file and write
code to call an endpoint
that will return an array of movie data
let's write code to import our axios
object from within our
axiosconfig.js file
let's import the use statehook and the
use effect Hook from react
let's return a destructured array from
the use statehook
the first item in the destructured array
is named movies and will store an array
of movie data returned from a call to
the relevant API endpoint
the second item in the array is a
function that can be used to change the
state of the movie's variable
when the state of the variable tracked
by react through the u-state hook is
changed the component is re-rendered by
react
so in this case the app component will
be re-rendered when the state of the
movies variable changes
let's create a function that will handle
a HTTP get request to an end point that
returns an array of movie data once the
movie data is successfully returned this
code that changes the state of the
movies array is executed
you can see here we are passing the
additional path information to the get
method
this path information is appended to the
base URL setting that we created when
setting up the configuration for axios
we are using async or weight for
asynchronous thread management
functionality on the client
I won't go into detail explaining async
await and promises but this
functionality can be effective in
ensuring that the UI is not blocked when
potentially long-running operations like
for example a remote API call are
processed
the UI thread will not be blocked and
therefore the user's screen will not for
example freeze the user screen will
still be responsive while a potentially
long-running i o bound operation is
processing
once the relevant task has completed the
code directly below the code that kicks
off the awaited process will be executed
so it's like a promises made to return
to the appropriate line of code once the
task potentially long-running i o bound
task for example has completed
as explained this async await
functionality is useful in order to
ensure a better ux user experience
in case something goes wrong during the
execution of our HTTP request let's wrap
the relevant code in a try catch block
and let's include code in the catch
block to log the relevant exception to
the browser console window
so you could be more thorough here in
your code and check the HTTP status code
for example if the HTTP status code
returned from the server is 200 this
indicates that the operation performed
on the server was successful
I'm not going to include this
functionality in this course in order to
keep the code fairly basic for our HTTP
requests that we are executing from the
client
let's implement the use effect hook so
that the get movies function is executed
when the app component first loads
let's also write code to log the results
return from the call to the relevant
endpoint to the browser console window
let's use the npm start command to run
our react application
let's look at the browser console window
to see if our results have been returned
from the server
excellent our HTTP get request made
through the use of axios executed
successfully
so
the next step is to start implementing
our routing functionality or routing
functionality
let's create a react component named
layout.js
let's open the layout.js file and import
the outlet component from the react
router Dom npm package
to generate boilerplate code for our
layout component we can type ra fce and
press the Tab Key like this
let's rather use semantic HTML here and
include main tags instead of div tags
within our main tags let's include a
reference to the outlet component
let's go back to the app.js file and
write code to import the layout
component that we have just created
right so I'm going to create a
components folder within the SRC folder
and move the layout.js file into the
components folder
let's write the code to import the
layout component into the app component
let's write code to import The Roots
component and the root component from
the react router Dom npm package
in The Return part of the app component
IE where jsx code is returned from our
component let's write code to establish
the root mappings as it were for our
applications react components so let's
first add the roots element here
within the roots element let's include a
parent root element
it's a parent root element because child
root elements will be included within
this parent root element like for
example a child root component that
points to the home component we'll write
the home component in a bit
will be a child of the parent root
component that points to the layout
component so the layout component
referenced through the outlet element in
the layout.js file denotes the
components pointed to by the child root
component references that we'll include
within the parent root element here
we'll include the relevant child route
elements as we progress with the
development of our react application
the next step is to open the index.js
file and write code to import
the browser router component The Roots
component and the root component into
the index component
let's include code to establish the
relevant root mapping for the app
component
great let's create our home component
let's first create a folder within the
components folder named home let's
ensure that the first letter in our home
folder name
is lowercase
let's add a file named home
with an uppercase H to our home folder
let's type in ra fce followed by
pressing the Tab Key to generate
boilerplate code for the home component
let's simply type in the text welcome so
that we can test our root functionality
we'll create the code for our home
component in just a bit
let's create the code for the root
element that points to our home
component within the app.js file
oops I can see a little bug in our code
this reference to layout
is not correctly formed let's include
the layout element properly within our
code here
let's type in npm start at our command
prompts and press enter to launch the
application
great
so let's create a component that will be
a child component of the home component
we'll name this component hero
this component denotes the hero section
of our home page
that will display items in a carousel
that are representative of movies to the
users of this application so let's
create a folder within the components
folder named hero
within the hero folder let's add a file
named hero.js
let's also add a file to the hero folder
named hero.css where we'll of course
include CSS code for our hero component
let's write code to import the hero.css
file into our hero component
let's import the carousel component from
the relevant material UI npm package
let's import the paper component from
the relevant material UI npm package
let's write code to destructure the
props passed into this component only
one destructured value containing an
array of movie data needs to be included
here
let's implement the carousel
functionality let's include the carousel
element like this
within the carousel element let's write
code to map each item in the movies
array to an item displayed in the
carousel
the paper element encapsulates each
movie item displayed in the carousel
let's include div tags so that the movie
poster is displayed as well as the movie
title is displayed for each Carousel
item
as you can see I've included CSS class
references in the relevant div tags
we'll style our components in the
hero.css file in a bit
where we'll implement the appropriate
CSS properties for these CSS classes
oops let's make sure that we are
importing the hero.css class correctly
here
let's open the home.js file and include
the hero element in the part of the code
that is returned as jsx code from the
home component
let's make sure that we are importing
the hero component into our home
component
let's write code to ensure that the
movies array is being passed down from
the app component to the home component
and subsequently the hero component
and that's great we are displaying the
relevant data from the Json data
returned from the relevant api's
endpoint but let's customize the styling
of our Carousel through CSS code
we can position our vs code editors
to a pane on the left side of our
screens and we can position our browsers
to obtain on the right side of our
screens like this
in this way we can watch the effects of
our CSS code changes in real time I'm
not going to go into a lot of detail
regarding the CSS code the code will be
available on GitHub where you can
examine it in more detail if you'd like
let's first update the CSS code in the
app.css file this CSS code affects all
components that are child components of
the app component
and you are able to observe the effects
of the CSS code on the browser in real
time as the CSS code evolves
so let's import the quicksand font from
Google with this line of code
let's set up the box sizing and font
Family Properties for all elements
let's set the body elements padding and
margin properties to zero
let's style the app class note that all
of our components are children of the
app component
let's remove this code
from the index.css file because it is
not needed
let's style the carousel component that
has been implemented within our hero
component so let's include our CSS code
in the hero.css file
and we are able to watch the effects on
the carousel displayed in our browsers
in real time as the relevant CSS code
evolves
and we don't actually want the poster
image to take up the carousel display as
it is at the moment we want an
appropriate backdrop image a larger
image to fill the background for each
item in the carousel
I want to include a gradient that Fades
from dark to light from the bottom of
each Carousel item to where the title is
displayed
in order to dynamically reference the
background image URL
for each Carousel card
I'm going to use a CSS custom variable
so we can do this by including an inline
style within the div element that
references the movie Dash card CSS class
and within that inline style assign a
variable to the property that we wish to
reference within the relevant CSS file
so here we are naming our custom CSS
variable
image
we are setting the CSS URL value to the
CSS background Dash image CSS property
from the backdrops property of each
movie in the movies array returned from
the server note that the backdrop's
property returned from the server is an
array containing paths to movie backdrop
images
in this code I'm choosing to reference
the first backdrop image path in the
backdrops array returned from the server
each backdrop points to an image that we
want displayed as a background image
appropriately for each movie item in the
carousel
we can now reference each background
image from within our CSS class and
style the background appropriately
so we are assigning the background Dash
image CSS property a gradient that Fades
from light to dark
this is just a stylistic choice for our
front-end display
you can see here in our CSS code how we
are using the dash dash image custom CSS
variable to link the URL property value
referenced in the jsx code in the hero
component to the background Dash image
CSS property in the hero.css file
you can see that the poster image is
looking distorted so let's style the
poster and the title appropriately
great and we have used absolute
positioning and the CSS Flex box to
style our poster and handle where it
appears in the layout
let's style the title appropriately
great
and our Carousel is looking pretty good
let's create the component to house our
navigation display let's create the
header component
so let's create a folder within the
components folder named header let's
create a file within the header folder
named header.js
let's import the appropriate font
awesome components
let's import the appropriate bootstrap
components
and let's use react bootstrap components
to create a responsive layout for our
navigation menu which will be displayed
at the top of the screen
this is one of the huge advantages of
using bootstrap it can save us a lot of
time in creating responsive layouts
we are using the fa video flash font
awesome icon for our logo that will be
displayed in the top left corner of our
screen within the navigation bar that we
are creating within the header component
the login and registration buttons are
being included here superficially
they are purely cosmetic indicating that
we could extend the functionality of
this application to include login and
registration functionality at a later
stage for example if we wanted to enable
users to create their own list of
favorite movies or a watch list the
watch list link here is also their
purely for cosmetic reasons we won't
Implement a watch list component in this
course
so above the roots functionality within
the app.js file let's reference the
header component
let's go back to the header.js file and
make sure that our Imports are correct
let's run the code
excellent our navigation bar and our
logo looks pretty good
The Next Step
is we want to be able for a user to
click a play button icon on each
Carousel item and for an appropriate
movie trailer to play we'll enlist the
help of the react player component for
this purpose
let's first create a folder named
trailer within the components folder
let's create a file named trailer.js
within the trailer folder
let's also create a file named
trailer.css within the trailer folder
let's create the relevant import code in
the trailer.js file
let's import the use params hook into
our code from the react router Dom npm
package a YouTube video ID will be
passed into this component as a
parameter so we are going to use the use
params hook to extract the relevant
parameter value from the relevant URL
the relevant parameter will contain a
YouTube video ID which will allow us to
play a YouTube video
which is a trailer of the relevant movie
to the user
let's import the react player component
let's import the trailer.css file
let's create the boilerplate code for
our trailer component by typing in rafce
and pressing the Tab Key
let's create a div container in which
our react player component will reside
let's assign the past and parameter
value to a const named key
then we can include the react player
component appropriately like this
we want the player to include controls
so here we can set the controls property
to true we can set the playing property
to true so that the relevant video plays
as soon as the trailer component loads
and lastly and most importantly we can
set the URL property to the relevant
video on YouTube so we can append the
relevant YouTube video ID stored in the
key const to the base YouTube address to
point react player to the YouTube video
that will be played with the react
player great
let's go to the app.js file and include
the relevant root information for the
trailer component
notice how we are able to let react
route to Dom know as it were about the
YouTube video ID parameter then our code
within the trailer component must access
let's include a play button icon
provided by font awesome within our
carousel
okay so the play button icon is present
but it needs to be appropriately styled
as it is Tiny at the moment let's go to
the hero dot CSS file and style the play
button icon appropriately
great
let's include a media query so that our
Carousel adapts to smaller screens
great let's go to the trailer.css file
and create CSS code so that the react
player takes up 90 of the viewport
height
lastly we need to create the link so
when the play button icon is clicked
that the trailer component is invoked
and the appropriate parameter is passed
through to the trailer component
so the trailer link property retrieved
from the server contains the entire URL
to the YouTube video
we only want to pass the ID of the
YouTube video to the trailer component
from the hero component
we can extract the YouTube video ID by
using the JavaScript substring method to
extract the last 11 characters from the
trailer link property like this
let's run the code
excellent
the last component we need to create is
the reviews component the reviews
component will enable users to view
reviews from other users as well as ad
reviews for movies into the system IE
which entails a HTTP post request being
made from our react component to the
relevant remote API endpoint carrying
the review data entered by the user and
the server-side Java code will then save
the review data appropriately to the
mongodb database firstly let's create a
component named review form this
component will contain a form component
that contains a text area control where
the user can enter text that denotes a
movie review a submit button will also
be included so that the user can click
this button in order to submit the
user's movie review
so let's create a folder named review
form
let's create a file named reviewform.js
within the review form folder
let's include the code for the
functionality we have just discussed
let's create the reviews component that
will be a parent component of the review
form child component
let's create a folder named reviews
let's include a file within the reviews
folder named reviews.js
let's include the appropriate import
code at the top of the reviews.js file
let's generate the appropriate
boilerplate code for the reviews react
component by typing in rafce and then
pressing the Tab Key
let's use the use ref hook to reference
the text area control within the review
form
let's use the use params hook so that we
can extract the movie ID parameter value
from the relevant URL
this movie ID is actually the IMDb ID of
the movie that we have retrieved through
the API call that is made to retrieve
the array of movie data from the server
the IMDb ID value of course is used to
uniquely identify a specific movie
so when our component first loads
we want to call a method that is passed
in as a prop to our component in order
to retrieve the appropriate data for the
relevant movie that the user wishes to
review so we can use the use effect hook
like this for this purpose
let's use react bootstrap components for
example the row and call components to
create an appropriate layout for the
reviews component
we want to display the poster for the
relevant movie
in the left part of the screen and the
reviews in the right part of the screen
we can use the row and call components
appropriately to achieve this
let's include the review form element
here like this
let's create a method named add review
and create the relevant HTTP post
request functionality for adding a
review to the mongodb database which
resides on a remote server
and let's write code to update the state
of the reviews array on the client side
optimistically meaning that we are not
using data returned from the server IE
data that is saved to the database for
updating the state of the reviews array
we are updating the array directly from
the data entered on the client
we also want to include code that clears
the relevant text area control once the
user has successfully submitted a review
we are updating the state of the reviews
array on the client through the use of
the set reviews method that will be
passed as a prop from the app component
let's go to the app.js file and create a
method that uses axios to make a get
request for data pertaining to a single
movie
so an IMDb ID value will be passed into
this method to the movie ID parameter
and a HTTP get request using the movie
ID value appropriately in the URL will
be made to retrieve data for a single
movie from the remote server
so let's set the state for the movie
variable
and to make our code clearer let's
extract the reviews array from the movie
data and track the state of the reviews
array
let's make sure that the appropriate
props are being passed down to the
reviews component
we are now able to create reviews for
the movies retrieved from the remote
server ultimately from a mongodb
database that stores our movie data so
we are adding reviews to our mongodb
database through an appropriate HTTP
post request to an appropriate endpoint
excellent
one thing we must do whenever we
Implement a list of uniquely
identifiable items in our jsx code like
this
appropriately includes the key property
for each list item to uniquely identify
each item in the carousel
we can set the key property
for each movie item
displayed within the carousel
to the appropriate IMDb ID value for
each movie
this value has been passed down to us
with the movie data array that we
retrieved from the remote server using
the appropriate HTTP get request
I hope you've enjoyed building this
front end using react and I hope you
feel that you have benefited from this
course
if you've got to the end of this course
you've done exceptionally well
thank you and take care